November 29th as the day of
international solidarity with the
Palestinian people it was designated in
1977 by the United Nations 30 years
after the general assembly charted its
own plan for the future for the
Palestinians and the Jewish people who
had settled in Palestine well Colin
Baker has more on how Israel's borders
have changed since
then in 1947 the United Nation's General
Assembly passed resolution 181 ending
Britain's occupation of Palestine and
partitioning it into two independent
states one Palestinian the other Jewish
it also classified Jerusalem as an
international City to be overseen by the
UN as trustee but the plan never came
into effect war broke out between
Zionist groups and Palestinians days
later and eventually Drew in neighboring
states the 1948 War resulted in the
nakba or catastrophy more than
750,000 Palestinians were forced from
their homes when Israel claimed control
of more than three4 of Palestinian land
and forbade Palestinians to return
because they were not Jewish by 1949
Israel had signed a series of armistice
agreements with neighboring states Egypt
would control the Gaza Strip and Jordan
the West Bank and East Jerusalem that
was the status quo until 1967 when war
broke out again between Israel Egypt
Syria and Jordan Israeli forces occupied
the West Bank Gaza and East Jerusalem as
well as the Golan Heights and the Sinai
Peninsula
the conflict lasted years culminating in
another war in 1973 between Israel Egypt
and Syria it wasn't until 1982 that
Israel withdrew from the Sinai it still
occupies the Golan Heights which borders
Lebanon and Syria in the Years following
the Oslo Peace Accords Palestine was
divided even further leaving more than
60% of the occupied West Bank under
Direct Control of the Israeli military
today about 700,000 Israeli settlers
live in the occupied West Bank in
roughly 300 settlements and outpost all
of which are illegal under international
law